everyone it's tomorrow i am here in
sony's offices and i am one of the first
people outside of sony to get my hands
on the playstation vr2 and i also just
played horizon call of the mountain
build by firestrike studios um first
things first the actual device the
playstation vr to it seems like it's
come a long way since the original
device i think the the most immediate
thing that you'll notice is the
comfortability um i put it on and pretty
much immediately there were a number of
options for me to get it onto my face
and in place
in the optimal way there's buttons on
the back buttons on the front um it now
allows you to adjust the
distance between the two lenses so you
can have it pretty much perfectly for
you um everything that you expect from
it still works you know if you want
glasses on glasses off
and uh the the big big ticket of of
course are the new um controllers which
are
based somewhat on the dualsense um and
they obviously take a lot of um
modernization and a lot of evolutions
from uh controller technology in the vr
space specifically the oculus stuff the
whole finger tracking stuff is something
that has been pretty much associated
with oculus's quests and riffs and that
kind of stuff and now it is a version of
it for the playstation vr2 and it works
really really well i know that because i
played horizon call of the mountain
which obviously if you played horizon
you will know involves a lot of bow and
arrow shooting but in this game in this
version of the game there's also a lot
of climbing um so which meant that i was
able to really check the fidelity of how
it feels to use your hands and whether
that's climbing up the up things like
ladders or scaling the side of mountains
or even doing things like picking up
apples or lids or barrels and kind of
really inspecting it um horizon call it
a mountain very impressive um i had one
of those moments where i was like oh
this is why vr is magical and it's worth
pursuing um start off on a boat ride
obviously you're playing a new character
for the this game specifically and you
begin with a classic vr
moment where you're sitting in a bowl
and you're kind of going through
an area from the game and it was pretty
incredible seeing
the world of horizon from that
perspective first person perspective it
would be enough but this is a immersed
vr first person perspective where you
can see all like the shrubbery and and
the bright colors and the mountains and
the and the brilliant blue sky and the
the blinding light of the sun and then
you get to see the various robot animals
kind of come and go and the sense of
scale is very very very overwhelming at
times um
i described it as having a jurassic park
moment where you know the sense of
wonder that you get in that you see in
that movie where those characters are
seeing dinosaurs you know wandering by
it was very very similar where you know
we had these these enemies that i'd been
seeing my entire life you've been
playing that franchise from the end of a
bow and arrow now up close and personal
and it was an impressive fidelity pretty
much everywhere that i looked there was
a high level of detail and and it was
very very impressive um the other thing
that i really liked about that um demo
that i played for horizon called the
mountain was it felt like an
amalgamation of a lot of the the
singular vr experiences that you would
have up until this point you had games
that were you know focused on oh you're
a tourist in this world so you kind of
just sit down and watch and get to enjoy
the environments or you play another one
which is like oh this is a bow and arrow
game where you a lot of the gameplay
elements and the gameplay design is
focused on you either shooting a gun or
firing a bow and arrow and there's all
this is a climbing game where the only
thing you really do is climb just put
all that together and put it in the wall
of horizon in a way that made a lot of
sense um so in any in my across my
entire playtime i went from simply
walking which is done by holding two
buns and then moving your hands up and
down which was felt quite intuitive and
it kind of
i felt it to be a good middle ground
between the previous two um
movement
methods that we're used to which is like
teleportation or like actively pressing
a stick to move forward i felt like i
had a little more control and i felt a
little more kind of involved in the
process which also helped reduce the
kind of sense of motion sickness that
people might um feel you know mileage
will still vary but as someone who is
motion sick i didn't feel myself
immediately looking to hurl up um my
breakfast
but i did enjoy that kind of feeling of
moving around so i walked around a bit i
got to inspect the environments and then
went from there and went into climbing
the climbing part of it very intuitive
simply holding down the triggers as i
was putting my hand in place and it was
almo it would almost snap to the
grabable ledges and then i was just
physically pulling myself up and it was
so intuitive that i kind of like really
got immersed in the the feeling of and
the process of like looking out for
handholds and then grabbing them and
then by the time i realized i was way
way high up a mountain and i did the
instinctive thing which was looking down
and
that overwhelming sense of peril that
you get from vr sometimes kind of came
over me so i had to really like tell
myself oh this will be fine don't worry
about it and i think that really speaks
to like the fidelity of what they've um
kind of rendered with this is like a
very beautiful very high res a very
detailed game so i i found that to be
quite impressive and then we went on to
some scenarios which are a little more
combat focused um the weapon i had was a
bow and arrow um picked up you can
choose what hand you want to kind of
wield it with and it does the classic vr
thing where you put it behind your back
and you can also like pull out um arrows
to use together and then it's manual
aiming there wasn't a reticle on site so
it was simply a case of like eyeballing
it and doing and letting your arrows fly
based on that which felt good it felt
like that's where like a lot of the
skills gonna come for um interestingly
obviously you cannot do a dodge roll in
this game because you will throw up so
the the kind of system that they've come
up with is you hold two buttons and kind
of like
swing your arms and then let go at the
end of it and your character will do a
hop in that direction there's pretty
much free movement up until combat major
combat scenarios so when you're walking
around the world you can look around in
kind of increments and then use the
movement method to move back and forth
however when you're in a big boss fight
you have almost like a path set out for
you so you'll only be able to dodge in
certain um along these paths you can't
like run forward and attack or run back
and attack or dodge and that kind of
stuff so it kind of is a little more
fixated to make sure that you're not
over overdoing it in terms of movement
um and then i also fought a bunch of
different scale of enemies which was the
impressive thing at one point in the in
the beginning you get to kind of see the
tallness walk by and it was it is very
very impressive to be underneath it and
look up and see that that that character
model in scale and it did make me think
i will be able to climb up to the top of
that and also um kind of like see the
world from the top down i spoke to the
developers fire spray and and um gorilla
afterwards and they talked about the
whole campaign lasting roughly seven
hours if you beeline it i don't expect
people will be lying at first time
through and there is a
lot of value in stopping to like really
suck in the scenery because as as i
mentioned playstation vr2 is a big big
step up based on the little i've played
so far from the original especially when
it comes to fidelity so you will want to
smell the virtual roses and pick arrows
out of enemies and kind of figure out
what
what how did what makes this world tick
so and and i found that rewarding if i
had more time i probably would have
spent way more time just walking around
and looking at stuff but based on the
little that i played i was very very
impressed one with call of the mountain
and two with the headset
i'm excited to get more time with the
headset and also that controller and
hopefully i'll be able to do that again
soon
thanks for watching keep it on gamespot
for more on horizon and playstation vr2
hey
shadow karja you can run but i will find
you
i'm not trying to run i'm
hey
so she's alive
and she thinks i'm trying to escape
hey